the associate cloud engineer track
enables you to become proficient with
Google cloud platform through hands-on
practice with quick labs the track
provides quick labs credits that you can
use to complete the labs free of charge
here are the steps to redeem quick labs
credits at the beginning of the program
an invitation email was sent to you from
Google cloud edu and Coursera and the
subject line you are invited to learn on
Coursera the email provides the link to
redeem quick labs credits and the access
code the link in the invitation email
will directly open quick labs the Google
cloud training platform and prompt you
for the access code here are the steps
using an example click the invitation
link copy and paste the access code as
prompted and click Submit sign into your
quick labs account click on join with
email to set up your Quick Labs account
setup your quick labs account enter your
first name last name and your email
address specify the same email address
that you use for your Coursera account
for company name specify your
institutions name or none enter password
enable the opt-in box to receive
information about new content and
special discounts after you complete the
cloud architecture quest enable CAPTCHA
and click create a new account once you
have created your Quick Labs account you
may verify that credits have been added
to your quick labs account click on the
user profile to review your quick labs
credit status click on the user profile
within your user profile click my
account and click on credits and
subscriptions for additional quick labs
account information redeeming quick labs
credits for the associate cloud engineer
track is a one-time process if you
already have a quick labs account and
enrolled in the cloud architecture quest
before
please unenroll in the quest and then
click the enroll button again only when
you click the enroll button will the
credits be applied to your account if
there are any other problems email
support at quick labs comm the team will
respond quickly we
now reviewed the steps to redeem quick
lab credits create your account verify
that quick labs credits have been added
to your account and that support at
quick labs comm is your resource for
troubleshooting assistance